alors il s'agit d'un homme de 33 ans
interpellé hier soir placé en garde à
vue il a été présent lors de la
perquisition du domicile du gardé à vue
âgé de 35 ans jeudi un premier suspect
âgé de 47 ans a été interpellé puisqu'il
a été vu sur des images de vidéo
surveillance aux côtés de l'assaillant
est la veille de l'attentât
tout l'intérêt de l'enquète ça va être
de déterminer le rôle de chacun savoir
s'ils ont pu apporter une quelconque
complicité un quelconque soutien
logistique à l'assaillante et l'objectif
de l'enquète ça va être aussi est de
déterminer le parcours exact de
l'assaillant alors ce que l'on sait
aujourd'hui c'est que ce tunisien de 21
ans a quitté son domicile familial situé
à sfax dans le centre de la tunisie mi
septembre qu'il a atteint l'europe par
l'île de lampedusa par la suite qu'il a
été aussi vu à bari dans le sud de
l'italie et puis d'après les premiers
éléments de l'enquète ce tunisien de 21
ans est arrivé à nice un ou deux jours
seulement avant l'attentât il n'a pas
encore pu être entendu par les
enquêteurs puisqu'il est toujours
hospitalisé dans un état critique son
pronostic vital est engagé depuis qu'ils
aient il a été neutralisé par les agents
de la police municipale lors de
l'attentât il a été touché par balles à
plusieurs reprises alors sa mère on dit
un peu plus sur la personnalité de son
fils elle dit qu'il était réparateurs de
motos qu'il était pas beaucoup en
contact avec le monde extérieur et puis
qui restaient souvent chez lui en
tunisie il avait des antécédents
judiciaires de droit commun et de
violences d'après la justice tunisienne
qui a également de son côté ouvert une
enquête voilà ce que l'on peut dire
aujourd'hui sur le profil de
l'assaillant qui continue de s'éclaircir
jour après jour